gagner autant d'argent ça fait péter les
plombs l'un et l'autre
ça aime trop cette question en France on
ne dit pas combien gagne moi en
Angleterre c'était affiché tout le monde
savait combien les personnes guerrier
aux États-Unis bon je sais pas voilà
donc vous trouvez que les Français ont
un problème avec ça avec la réussite ou
avec l'argent avec la jalousie avec la
jalousie vous vous dites quoi
[Applaudissements]
et plus les gens sont fiers de toi c'est
ça
un sujet tabou après je pense que là il
parlait des copains de chez le Verdez
voilà
chaque consigne merci d'être là Charles
je suis tellement contente de pouvoir
j'adore j'adore te voir tu sais que je
suis assez fan de toi tu as poussé un
gros coup de gueule ce matin regarde
il y aura toujours des besoins regarde
en ce moment délivrer Rubert bien sûr
[Musique]
tu es serveur moi j'étais content d'être
serveur mais oui c'est un boulot comme
un autre mais moi
[Musique]
ne plus être serveur c'est ma liberté
le cul aussi si tu es pas moche hein
alors
c'est vrai que voilà donc c'est Charles
Ivan c'est bon on l'aime bien alors vous
est-ce que vous trouvez on va on va
Charles va réagir est-ce que vous
trouvez que les Français sont jaloux
est-ce que vous êtes d'accord avec David
Ginola et Tony Parker oui non s'il vous
plaît vous avez des petites pancartes
oui Kelly vous dites NON bah moi je
pense pas que ça de la jalousie je pense
que si c'est de la tristesse et les gens
sont malheureux en ce moment en France
et des fois il y a des choses qui sont
pas entendables donc en fait quand tu
gagnes 1000 euros par mois bah tu as pas
envie d'entendre parce que tu es pas
spécialement heureux avec ce que tu as
parce que tu peux plus vivre avec donc
tu as pas envie d'entendre un mec qui
gagne 100000 par mois je peux le
comprendre Géraldine alors ce qui est
différent dans leur cas c'est qu'ils ont
fait fortune ils gagnent leur vie aux
États-Unis ou en Angleterre et donc ça
elles ont été riches à l'étranger ça
veut dire que quelque part quand il
revient en France ils reviennent avec
l'idée qu'en fait ils sont millionnaires
ou milliardaires mais de l'étranger
alors que vous c'est pas pareil vous
vous faites de l'argent ou vous gagnez
votre vie et très très bien en France
ici donc je pense que le rapport à
l'argent et à la réussite n'est pas le
même pour vous que pour eux mais oui moi
je pense que malgré tout en France il y
a quand même aujourd'hui encore plus
peut-être une sorte d'exaspération des
gens qui ont de l'argent des gens qui
réussissent regarder par exemple Bernard
Arnault oui
les pauvres sont gentils et les riches
sont méchants et voilà et on est
forcément
on a un peu d'argent on est forcément
suspect on est il y a des discours
un petit peu un peu du racisme anti-rid
je suis chez vos amis j'ai Bernex vos
amis là c'est pas mes amis mais c'est
vrai qu'ils ont un discours très
offensif contre les riches et ceux qui
ont fait fortune mais toi tu es riche ou
tu es pauvre moi j'ai toujours dit
moi j'entendais
les filles on veut plus de riche moi ce
que j'aimerais c'est avoir que des
riches
on serait heureux que tout le monde
gagne très bien sa vie c'est pas on peut
pas que tout le monde soit pauvre
sur le plan du capitalisme mais je pense
que il ne faut jamais diaboliser le
travail et moi j'en veux à une certaine
gauche qui commence un peu à expliquer
que au fond la société peut fonctionner
et que les gens peuvent s'en sortir sans
travailler ou sans vraiment travailler
moi je pense qu'aucun sa lune est
possible sans travail je pense qu'on ne
fait rien de bien son travail et je
pense que il faut que le travail
continue à être rémunéré correctement et
qu'on peut pas comme ça décrété
[Rires]
à l'extérieur c'est quelqu'un qui m'a
glissé ça je ne sais pas
vous avez un peu un look à lameric Caron
peut-être qu'il y a une barre
de la parole
n'est pas français toute l'année
tester des gouvernants de prendre ça en
compte cette envie de justice dans le
pays et c'est vrai qu'en France il y a
plus d'ascenseurs sociales aujourd'hui
moi je vois les jeunes qui sont normales
sup les NA pour une grande part d'entre
eux leurs parents étaient anormal sup
les nains etc donc ça c'est sûr qu'il y
a quelque chose à faire c'est sûr que
aujourd'hui les salaires de ce qu'on a
appelé pendant le covid avec des larmes
de crocodiles les premiers de corvées
sont trop faibles et moi je ne vois pas
pour l'instant ce qui est fait là-dessus
j'ai lu la dernière interview du
président de la République qui renvoie
au dialogue social et aux entreprises
pour l'augmentation des salaires à mon
avis il s'enlève les mains un peu vite
évidemment que tout ça doit être pris en
compte mais justement moi j'en veux à
cette gauche là toujours quand même à la
CGT la CFDT etc qui parce qu'elles
diabolise le travail elle empêche aussi
les gens de s'en sortir en France
aujourd'hui quand vous voulez recruter
quelqu'un quand vous voulez ouvrir votre
magasin tard quand vous voulez ouvrir
votre magasin dimanche quand vous êtes
une start-up qui installe des
trottinettes dans Paris qui était la
planche de salut des parisiens pour
survivre à Hidalgo elle a supprimé ça
tout ça ça crée 90% non ça ça a été et
combien de boomer parmi les électeurs
par rapport au nombre de jeunes c'était
une fausse sélection tout ça tout ça
tout ça ça crée oui mais elle a fait
exprès tout ça ça crée des conditions
qui font que vous n'avez pas en France
la possibilité de trouver si facilement
du boulot quand vous êtes justement dans
un milieu défavorisé donc je trouve
qu'il y a un grand chantier mais que
c'est pas en revenant à nos vieilles
lunes socialisantes qui à mon sens ont
plutôt miné notre pays qu'autre chose
qu'on avancera même si je pense que la
justice ça fait partie de notre noblesse
ça fait partie de l'idéal français c'est
quelque chose qui doit être pris en
compte du luxe dans un projet politique
Gilles pardon mais tu dis n'importe quoi
ma couille déjà en France il y a une
réalité il y a un tabou autour de
l'argent je pense que personne ne dirait
autour de cette table combien il gagne
sauf peu de chance
je ne gagne rien
n'oubliez pas à le reprendre
mais ce que je n'aime pas chez les gens
comme Gilles c'est qu'il y a des gens
qui pensent que la situation financière
des gens est figée à de vitamine
c'est-à-dire que les pauvres sont
dessinés pauvres toute leur vie et que
les riches sont destinées à être riches
toute leur vie mais je suis désolé il y
a des mecs qui ont commencé au SMIC en
étant chauffeur uber qui sont devenus
des grands joueurs de foot des grands
basketteurs des grands patrons des
grands chefs d'entreprise donc ces mecs
au lieu des jalouser on devrait les
admirer il faut les admirer ce mecs là
faut être positif
et c'est vrai que c'est un souci non
parce que je levais la main depuis tout
à l'heure et en fait non je pense que
c'est vraiment un souci moi je le vois
avec les émissions quand on les fait
c'est la question qu'on veut toujours
enlever quand les artistes viennent ils
veulent toujours enlever la question du
salaire et en même temps dans la rue à
chaque fois qu'on pose quelque chose on
dit ah vous donner vous vous posez la
question des salaires aux gens la
dernière fois on l'avait fait avec toi
Géraldine je t'avais posé la question du
salaire ça a été sur internet c'est un
truc de fou
je te remercie je me suis fait encore
plus démontée
après on est plus légitime pour parler
genre toi qui gagne tous les soirs pour
rien dire tu es hors-sol tu sers à rien
de toute façon tu comprends pas tu sais
pas ce que c'est la vraie galère mais
les gens ne savent pas en fait ne
connaissent pas la vie des gens ils
savent pas qu'on a 51 51 ans on sait pas
ce qu'on a vécu avant on sait pas où on
en est de notre situation personnelle et
tout ça donc voilà on juge vite et donc
forcément il y a une jalousie Raymond
toi qui te balade toute la journée dans
ton camion tu dis OUI tu dis non tu as
une petite pancarte je te laisse le
temps je reviens vers toi dans 2 minutes
[Rires]
moi je dis oui alors jaloux je sais pas
si c'est jaloux ou en vieux on est
jaloux du voisin qui a une belle voiture
on est jaloux du voisin quand il peint
ses volets quand il change son portail
moi j'ai commencé moi j'ai vu un
changement en tout cas pour parler de
moi moi j'ai vu un changement qui était
j'ai commencé à bosser à 5115 francs
donc 780 euros à l'époque et tout
doucement mais ça a l'air sont montés
1005 2000 2005 3000 3005 jusqu'à
parfois même plus c'est juste prix
mais quand c'est comme ça tu fais tu
fais ton mode de vie et j'ai toujours eu
des voitures moi j'ai toujours kiffé les
voitures donc j'ai acheté les voitures
qui avaient beaucoup de kilomètres mais
des fois des berlines allemandes qui a
beaucoup de kilomètres quand je faisais
pas de télé et qu'on pouvait pas
s'imaginer mon salaire on m'a jamais dit
ah tu es jaloux de ta voiture on m'a dit
c'est bien parce que tu es livreur tu as
une belle voiture tu te démerdes bien
maintenant que je fais de la télé ah ça
paie ça paye Hanouna ça paye la bagnole
alors
c'est ça et même même à mon propre
travail les mecs me disent mais pourquoi
tu continues à travailler maintenant que
tu as plein de l'argent tu sais pas si
c'est déjà jalousie ou pas alors qu'on a
pas énormément d'argent c'est pas c'est
pas avoir on a plus d'argent que les
gens on est pas milliardaire et le
meilleur exemple c'est que bien sûr
qu'en France il faut se cacher parce que
si tu as une Ferrari si tu as une
Porsche si tu as des grosses voitures de
luxe tu aimes pas les montrer tu aimes
pas les faire voir tu sors en cachette
et le meilleur exemple c'est ici est-ce
que en France l'argent est à bout est-ce
que tout son tour là c'est pas de dire
combien on gagne est-ce qu'on est
capable de ramener notre feuille
d'impôts et de la montrer aux Français
il y en a aucun qui va le faire aucun
c'est pour ça qu'on dit non aucun mais
donc c'est bien un tableau donc c'est
bien un tabou et c'est bien que les gens
sont jaloux Charles consignes
je pense que il y a en France une soif
de justice forte mais il y a aussi eu à
creusement des inégalités très
importantes il y a eu une un
accroissement des inégalités en France
et il y a de plus en plus des gens qui
vivent entre eux selon leur classe
sociale et qui ne se et qui ne se
mélangent plus moi je considère que
aujourd'hui la responsabilité elle est
quand même du côté des patrons qui ne
peuvent pas simplement s'émouvoir de
voir des cortèges de manifestations et
des gens qui refusent des réformes et
qui doivent même prendre leur
responsabilité on peut pas tout attendre
de l'État dans une dans une aux Grandes
Gueules justement dans cette émission
qu'on s'était tout à l'heure un jour on
avait une auditrice qui était salarié
dans un une grande chaîne de
d'hypermarchés elle était rémunérée
dizaine de 1000 euros par mois moins de
1000 euros par mois pour un contrat de
30 heures elle devait se lever à 5 ou 6
heures du matin pour prendre sa bagnole
pour aller bosser et elle n'arrivait pas
à payer son carburant pour aller bosser
et que faisait le gouvernement au lieu
de se dire c'est pas normal qu'elle soit
si peu payée pour ce job qui est
difficile pour lequel elle a des
conditions des horaires qui sont
difficiles il lui fait un chèque
carburant donc en fait sur deniers
publics on finance un système qui permet
à des très grandes entreprises et donc
quand même à des grands patrons à des
grands actionnaires etc de sous-payer
les salariés moi je trouve qu'il
faudrait changer le la focale
c'est-à-dire ce qu'on a perdu Jordan
Deluxe
plus de 10000 euros par mois honnêtement
tu vas pas le foot je peux tout à fait
raison
d'abord j'ai une légère phobie
administrative qui fait que je regarde
peu j'ai des revenus fluctuants l'année
dernière j'ai gagné moins de 2000 euros
par mois l'année d'avant j'ai gagné plus
voilà 2011
non mais j'adore je l'adore ça oui ou
pas oui mamie t'as pas réagi toi j'ai
l'impression quand même que c'est une
légende toi tu es toujours payant
[Rires]
en pistolet j'ai l'impression que c'est
un peu une légende urbaine quand même
parce que regarder les grands
footballeurs j'étais un peu gêné que
David Ginola et Tony Parker dit ça
l'autre jour on les adore ils sont hyper
populaire donc je pense que franchement
c'est vrai que moi j'aurais
du mal à entendre des grossir mais on a
du mal à le dire ça dépend des
infirmières alors on passe pour des
magots
il fait rire les gens il fait une
émission excusez-moi
tout le monde ça dépend énormément de
gens adorent Cyril on sait qu'il est
quand même assez à l'aise on va dire les
réseaux sociaux
enfin voilà tu crois que les gens ils
sont pas jaloux de toi tu restes trois
heures comme ça avec une pancarte pour
faire ça
elle a fêté les matins après les pirates
et les matins à la fin du truc
là les gens ils sont jaloux comment ça
se fait que c'est tout le temps
on se retrouve là juste pour faire oui
non elle doit prendre deux trois quatre
mille balles pour rester le cul 3 heures
sur une chaise avec des lumières
démaquillage
de ça ok mais c'est pareil on voit bien
que c'est du shopping les gens ils font
autre chose le reste de la journée
Tony Parker aussi parce que c'est une
star qui sont dans un certain milieu etc
mais dans la vraie vie vous pouvez pas
et même là c'est là où je comprends
qu'il y a un tableau auto d'argent vous
pouvez pas vous mettre en face de
quelqu'un qui gagne le SMIC et lui dire
écoute moi je gagne 10 20 30 40 100000 €
par mois parce que c'est indécent parce
que c'est vulgaire d'en parler en
revanche il faut être positif là-dessus
il faut pas attiser une haine des riches
et encourager les gens qui en ont envie
parce que c'est pas une fin en soi pour
tout le monde de devenir millionnaire
milliardaire de gagner plus d'argent et
rien n'est figé on peut évoluer dans la
vie on peut comme l'a dit ce matin
Charles on peut se bouger le cul aussi
et il y a des gens qui arrivent très
bien donc voilà mais le tabou sur
l'argent je le comprends c'est inhumain
direct et il a dit
le coût du travail il a dit quelque
chose d'important au lieu de donner des
aides à chaque fois aux gens essayons de
parce qu'on regarde toujours moi c'est
toujours pareil je rate regardez ce qui
se passe ailleurs regardez en Angleterre
regardez en Allemagne regardez en
Espagne le coup du travail en France le
coup du travail en France il est plus
élevé que par toi ailleurs donc au lieu
de donner des aides de un chèque à une
bonne femme qui comme il a dit à une
dame qui va travailler lui donner un
chèque de 100 euros peut-être mais
arrêtez arrêtez bien sûr qu'on paye bien
sûr qu'on va le payer bien sûr mais
c'est tout le temps vous sortez tout le
temps la même rengaine à chaque fois
vous nous sortez qu'on va être malade
alors on va crever de faim sous prétexte
bien sûr que je suis fier il vaut mieux
avoir un truc mais bien sûr que je suis
fier il a eu un cancer bien sûr que je
suis fier quand on va avancer les
montants que j'ai rien payé bien sûr
j'étais fier et ben arrêtons de dire à
chaque fois bien sûr bien sûr
mais on sait bien qu'on paye les impôts
pour ça il y a pas que pour ça aussi il
faut trouver aussi d'autres solutions
arrêtez de taxer dans tous les sens
c'est ça le problème on va voir ce qu'on
pense
non à 20h
alors moi je suis d'accord avec les
autres et oui non mais voilà c'est comme
ça voilà et puis en Amérique on est fier
de la réussite monsieur Bava dit babarte
aux États-Unis mais j'ai essayé tu vois
tu as pas réussi
au gars là-bas c'est là que j'ai trouvé
des chiens qui tombent d'une échelle il
y en a partout hein qui pète c'est ça oh
ça va calme-toi
allez merci Charles d'avoir été avec
nous on vous retrouve demain dans les
Grandes Gueules ou pas non lundi pas
très bien il sera lundi dans les grandes
gueules
et le regarder ça marche bien hein mais
c'est vrai toi tu es content de l'avoir
vu non merci
de se lever pour trouver mais non c'est
l'inégalité qui tue la France il y a des
gens qui ne peuvent plus travailler
comme il le veut on est très destiné en
France
pour une part c'est vrai il y a cette
prédestination et cetera mais il faut
pas je pense que c'est un discours qui
est extrêmement démotivant moi je fais
payer des motivants moi je fais un
métier avocat pardon dans lequel
franchement à peu près tout le monde
peut réussir alors c'est sûr les fils de
ils vont faire leurs études à la fac un
peu plus facilement parce qu'ils vont
avoir des cours privés ils vont trouver
leur stage un peu plus facilement parce
que papa maman vont par leur réseau leur
trouver un bon cabinet mais si ils sont
nuls ils ne survivront pas dans un bon
cabinet ils n'auront pas de ça ils ne
seront pas considérés par les bons
avocats tandis que quand vous pouvez
venir de nulle part vous pouvez vous
faire un nom comme avocat vous pouvez
devenir un grand avocat et d'ailleurs
c'est le cas de la plupart des grands
avocats du barreau de Paris la plupart
sont des gens qui ont des origines
sociales modestes et il y a quand même
en pense énormément de métiers dans
lesquels on peut faire ça donc je sais
bien que le discours de gauche a très
largement contaminé toutes les sphères
de la société y compris Gilles Verdez
mais je pense que moi je veux défendre
encore le discours de l'émancipation et
du travail et je pense que c'est encore
possible sous réserve pour les pouvoirs
publics de rééquilibrer là où c'est
nécessaire de mettre de la justice là où
c'est nécessaire de mieux payer les gens
qui le méritent et de Tordre un peu le
bras quand il y a trop de concentration
de richesse des grands patrons des
actionnaires d'ailleurs je finis par là
par exemple moi je suis pour que les
salariés soient mieux représentés dans
les conseils d'administration des
entreprises avec des vrais représentants
qui est un pouvoir aussi grand que
n'importe quel membre du conseil
d'administration pour que la question
des salariés soit tout le temps sur la
table